this story did not come out of thin air
Susan this was something that was
inspired by your own life can you
explain exactly how yes I grew up with a
man his name was not mr. Church I
changed the name for the movie but he
came into my life when I was a little
girl and through strange circumstance
not exactly how I did in the movie but
he came through into my mom's life in my
life when my mom was sick with cancer
and I was little and he basically never
left my life until the day he died and
he raised me and nurtured me and fed me
and is the reason I became a writer and
is the reason I survived childhood and
he was the most important man in my life
and when he passed away I my daughter
had not been born yet and I was really
sad that she was never gonna meet this
incredible person who who just is the
reason for everything about my Who I am
today and so I thought well maybe I can
have them meet in a story and that was
sort of the beginning and and then I I
started I just started writing the story
and I took creative liberties with
certain things the major one being that
and I'm really sad to say my mom's alive
I never thought I'd have to apologize
for that horrible news but she she was a
miracle she just like in the movie
though she was dying of cancer we had
the hospital bed and all that um she did
survive her cancer but for most of my
life I lost her to alcoholism and in a
in a way that is another form of a death
in my life and the real mr. Church
really was the person that it came home
to the person who did my homework with
me the person who sowed my he's so close
for me so close for my dolls he you know
gave me the books to read and and he was
the he was my constant I'm happy to say
my mom is 84 and she is sober at 79
years of age
and so but yeah I had to kill her you
know it's just hi that's when creative
writing kicks in I didn't find out that
she was the life to a halfway through
the movie she came to set this is my
mother I didn't want well because I
tried I remember early on telling
Natasha about my mom and she's like
whether make your rooms alive and I'm
like okay I'm not gonna talk about my
mom for the rest of the movie because
it's gonna mess with them and but you
know when I watched the film you know I
realize all those thoughts of you know
my mom had been the son to me and and
burning and stuff is very similar to
also losing a parent to alcoholism when
they're just not there anymore and but
so I feel like I gave her a much more a
romantic to have then I think I just
think it's so much better that she's
alive so yeah that was I like that Bruce
Bruce if there's something that ties
this film together with the film that
you directed that won the Academy Award
for Best Picture Driving Miss Daisy it's
the idea of an unlikely friendship that
that blossoms between two people is that
something as a concept that appeals to
you and one of the reasons why you were
interested in doing this film now I
never really I never thought at all
about Driving Miss Daisy when I read
Susan's script when it first came to me
I just thought it was a very moving
story that was obviously true I mean I
could tell when I read it I thought well
this must have happened or most of it
and I found it terribly affecting and I
remember calling the producer Lee Nelson
who's here tonight and saying I think
it's a wonderful script and I don't even
need to find out if it's a true story or
not because I can tell that it is
because it had such integrity and
Driving Miss Daisy didn't relate I mean
it was just a film about some very
interesting people in a situation that I
found very touching Eddie it's been four
years since we've seen you
on screen in a feature film we're
you actively looking to come back and
you were seeking scripts out and that's
how you found mr. Church or did it come
across your desk and you thought I just
have to do it even though I've been
taking yeah I wasn't looking to do
anything I was just home in the backyard
relaxing and this came along and I
jumped on it was really nice thing to to
get involved with I'd never read
anything like it before and so I just
jumped on but I wasn't actively looking
for scripts what nor nor am I now well
that's a bummer to hear what about it
spoke to you I just like he I had a very
strong emotional reaction to it like
I've never read anything like that and
usually I don't get offered things like
that
so it was like I've never had the
experience where I was sitting and
crying while I was reading something so
I was like wow I never had this feeling
before and it was do something we hadn't
done before I've been making movies for
35 years so to get to do something you
haven't done before you know thank you
thank you
do something new you know Susan
obviously as you're saying there's
creative license here between the
inspiration for mr. Church and mr.
Church himself but having said that was
there any video footage or photographs
of the inspiration for the character
that you showed either Bruce or Eddie
the hell photographs you know what I
what I loved about Eddie's performance
first of all is his performance just
takes my breath away
every time I see it and you know I
showed him a couple pictures but we he
really trusted the material the person
was on the page and and you know it was
it was great he didn't we didn't need to
have like somehow Wow of like who you
know because really wait what it's from
the observation of me you know if this
was mr. churches story it would be a
whole different story but it was my
observations which is why I used
voiceover because so much of my
experience and my relationship with with
him was through
nations and thoughts and and just I
watched him all the time I was just so
in love with him and so he showed them a
couple of pictures and and the paintings
a lot of the paintings in the movie are
the real mr. churches that we use but
other than that you know I don't have
any footed video I and and and Eddie
didn't need I mean the first day when I
saw him in costume and just down to how
he held the cigarette it was it was it
gave me goosebumps cuz it was just and I
said to him I'm like it's crazy the
mannerisms and the way you're the way
you're carrying yourself is exactly how
he he really held a cigarette like that
never did you ever did you ever have a
note from a potential producer or a
distributor to encourage you to change
I'm really glad that it's from her point
of view I think that's special about the
film was there anyone who tried to get
you to switch it I was so spoiled on
this project and it'll never happen well
it took over 12 years to get this made
but so I hope that part doesn't happen
but the process the blue making of the
movie was so the between Bruce and his
honoring my script I mean he he let me
be on the set every day he let me be
imposed yeah you know you did you did
and and the producers everybody made the
movie I wrote you know they didn't try
to turn and you know the fact that not
all the answers of who mr. Church was
and the secrets and stuff are revealed
because that wasn't revealed to me and I
feel like in movies we want to always
sort of wrap things up in a nice neat
bow and you know spell it all out for
the audience and the truth is I'd rather
an audience just experience this
friendship and love and maybe go home
tonight and what did you think that
might be underneath all that you know
and come to their own ideas I think we
don't give audiences enough credit for
being smart and having their own
thoughts about you know characters but I
know I was so spoiled they didn't try to
make it something it was
and I'm so grateful for that the
performance I agree with you Susan Eddy
the performance is so understated so
beautiful so restrained KITT Bruce can
you talk about how the two of you work
together to help foster that and create
that did you try things at different
pitches and calibrations or was it
really kind of set in this beautiful
tone from the Gecko well I think we both
felt the same about it from the
beginning from when I first met Eddie at
his house and we talked about it we
obviously had had the same reaction to
the script and we seemed to be on the
same wavelength about the way the
character would behave and what he would
do and it was a great will it was a
great thrill working with Eddie because
I always used to feel it was always
seemed right to me you know I don't know
that I ever said that much I used to
maybe like there were time there were
times when because I'm always trying to
come up with something funny so there
were times where I would say you know be
funny Bruce if you did and he would go
it's very funny but I don't think it
works for you there's lots of times
where you kept it from you know going to
a joke but it was maybe maybe I did yes
it was I found I used to get I always
get very carried away and in films that
I'm directing because I wouldn't be
directing them if they didn't mean a lot
to me and when we were doing scenes like
the one in the garden you know where he
talks about the the ladybug and the
thing I I found it almost unbearably
moving and even now when I watch it I
think that said so beautifully down I'm
so I'm so proud of it and the it
it was so tricky you know in the short
time we had and Eddie's concentration
was so so fine and so total I was really
carried away in fact the whole cast for
that matter I thought all the subsidiary
characters Britt Lucy Xavier I thought
they were all very fine Susan you were
speaking to the fact that you wrote this
12 years ago and it's been a long road
what's the closest you came to feeling
like it was completely falling apart
that way it was never going to
happen oh my gosh I mean basically until
Eddie came on every time you know you
know we it looked like it was gonna
happen it just didn't and you know I
it's funny but I though say it was
everything happened exactly as it's
supposed to because this was waiting for
Eddie to do it really I can't imagine
anybody else playing it and to be
playing he it's such an honor that he
did it and that and I know that the real
mr. Church would be honored that he was
a fan of Eddie's you know and and I also
think I wrote it originally because my
daughter was not going to know the real
mr. Church and in a weird way she's
grown up with him because it's been
living in our home she's seen me try to
get it made she's she read a draft of it
when she was 10 years old you know
I mean she's watched it and and she's
heard me to health stories and talk
about is so in a strange way he grew up
with her after all and I'm just so I
look at it I don't now look and go oh
god you know I I'm like thank you that
it happened the way it was supposed to
you know well it's such a pleasure to
have all of you here and congratulations
on the film and thank you all for
sticking around tonight